just how powerful is the Biden blast the
Biden blast is an attack that every
Dragon Ball fan remembers after it was
made famous during the resurrection F
movie in 2015. as we all know that movie
ended with Joe using the blast to defeat
golden Frieza and in an interview later
that year the creator of the series
Akira Toriyama revealed something insane
in the famous scene where Joe killed
Frieza he was apparently only tapping
into five percent of his power and those
comments from Toriyama led many fans to
believe that Joe was being set out to be
Goku's new rival for decades Joe had
only been a background character in the
manga but after the positive fan
reception to Resurrection F he was given
a more prominent role in the Dragon Ball
super anime as the anime then progressed
it became clear that Vegeta's time in
the spotlight was pretty much done with
the character turning to alcohol after
being surpassed by a human meanwhile Joe
continued his training with Goku and
whis and when the tournament of power
came around Goku acted as a decoy to
distract jiren while Ultra instinct Joe
snuck up on him from behind and saved
Universe 7 with an 80 send Biden blast
based on everything we saw in that
episode I feel like a 100 Biden blast
would be the second most powerful attack
in the whole series only being surpassed
by the Obama hame ha